leaders including the french president
and the european commission head have
published a joint article
calling for a coordinated approach to
fighting the pandemic
the pandemic calls for a strong
coordinated international response
that rapidly expands access to tests
treatments and vaccines
recognizing extensive immunization as a
global public good
that must be available and affordable
for all
however some of the eu's closest
neighbours are yet to receive
any jabs bosnia and herzegovina kosovo
and the republic of north macedonia are
among the countries still
empty-handed more than a month after the
european union started its vaccination
campaign
independent journalist luke river
believes the situation
could have been handled better it was
very badly managed simply they didn't
sign the contract
right contracts they they you know they
were
completely wrong in every account
now the about two percent of the
european population
has been vaccinated with the first owes
europe is
really showing that it doesn't function
it's only last
friday that the astra seneca vaccine is
only being
accepted by europe on friday last week
i mean europe accepted the ema the
european medicine
agency accepted it for the 65 plus
but then some countries don't accept it
it cannot work like that
if there is an okay at european level
that isn't okay
so it's it's not functioning
you